yes so in light of the what you're
speaking about the importance of getting
across your message and the sort of
opposition that you've seen to the fight
against prop 8 which I'm curious what
you think is most valuable to your cause
is it the role is that you've had in a
fur and the like a Harvey Milk
foundation or would it be the more
subtle role that you have as a filmmaker
and sort of focusing and forming public
opinion well the one of the truly almost
insanely fortuitous and exciting moments
of my life was as heart the movie milk
started to come together and I was going
to get the chance to be one of the
producers because you know these were
the two great loves of my life
moviemaking and activism and pacifically
LGBT activism and wet there was this
moment where I was like is this really
going to happen that I'm gonna get to do
something that brings them both together
you know that was that was beyond
anything I'd ever dreamed of I mean I
always sort of thought that I would have
both loves I didn't ever hope to believe
that I'd have one project that would
that would be both of them and so but
the answer to your question is I mean I
think in a perfect world it's both you
don't it you it's both you don't ever
want to be either or but I am in this
very blessed position having these two
strains where you get to do both you
know there's a lot of people who only
have a career in the film business or
who only work in social justice and
politics and social activism and so
they're more or less stuck in one or the
other they can try and subtly affect
things by making great movies and TV
shows or they can actually be out there
raising money and campaigning I get
great fulfillment and passion by doing
both specifically because I do think you
know that they build on each other I
mean the the case now too because of its
Rob Reiner and Chad Griffin and dustin
lance black and myself and others you
know we're bringing our our our
Hollywood background and experience to
how do we produce this case in the most
effective way possible how do we get the
message out you know our our goal is we
want everything that a fur does in
associating with in association with
this case to just be the classiest most
informative most you know clearest
message possible and and so we've really
we've really strive to do that